welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and this one's for the
kids
and um the adults who spent christmas
watching disney's latest movie soul
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the film's ending
some of its easter eggs and the true
meaning behind it if you enjoyed the
video then please hit the thumbs up
button
and also make sure you subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns like this each
and every day
now the movie itself follows joe gardner
a music teacher who suffers a critical
injury before getting his big break
before you can say
have you been in an accident that wasn't
your fault joe is transported to the
soul world which is where spirits arrive
before heading into the great beyond
due to having unfinished business on
earth joe breaks out of this purgatory
between worlds
and lands in the great before which is
where souls are given their
personalities before being born
posing as a mentor in order to not get
sent back he's assigned to a problem
soul named 22 who doesn't want to be
born because well she's probably seen
2020.
now in order to journey to earth these
young souls have to fill up a travel
badge that
basically builds them with personality
traits and the pair agree to make a deal
to fill it up so that joe can take it
and return
there's a moment in the movie in which
there's a ton of easter eggs
and during the trip through the hall of
everything we can see the balloon from
up
as well as the planet pizza truck which
has appeared in every pixar movie
there's also the infamous lamp that
makes up their logo
and the whole of everything is filled to
the brim you may remember that there was
a pizza rat spotted in new york a couple
of years ago
and this even makes an appearance in the
movie now seoul sort of becomes somewhat
of a body swap film with the pair
actually making it to earth
but joe lands in a cat whereas 22 takes
over his body
soul is very much about finding the
beauty in life and we see as 22
experiences things on earth such as
eating pizza for the first time
having a subway blow the wind up through
you seeing happy families and so on and
probably
subscribing to the heavy spoilers show
now the movie kind of goes back and
forth with 22 and joe going on a journey
as he tries to get back to his body so
he can perform at the gig
and make it to his big break however the
film
also allows 22 to come to the
understanding that there is good in the
world
and that she will have a reason to live
now joe believed that the only thing
worth doing was playing jazz
and that if he wasn't able to do this
then life simply wouldn't have a meaning
thus he's fixated on this thing at the
expense of everyone around him
in the movie we journey to a realm known
as the zone which is where those lost
and what they do travel to
however there's also a downside to it
and souls can become trapped there
if they've turned something into an
unhealthy obsession these people's lives
have sort of lost their meaning
and became disconnected because they are
fixated on one thing instead of all
aspects of life
the message of the movie for me is that
though there are things such as your
spark which drive your existence
that shouldn't be the only thing your
existence is about
we meet these sort of angel like
creatures in the film called jerry's
who explain that a spark fills a hole
but that many people fall into the trap
of thinking that they exist just for one
reason
joe at one point in the film even says
that he exists
solely to play and that nothing else
matters
i know on a personal level i i've kind
of just fallen into making youtube
videos non-stop this year instead of
actually taking some time off
and though i love what i do this message
did mean something to me
i think many of the adults watching this
and yeah i know you'll be out there
have probably had times where they
wanted to do something with their kids
friends or family but that something
else has just gotten away
and thus they've spent too much time
focusing on that rather than having a
balanced life joe got a full-time job
teaching music to kids
but he still didn't care and because of
his obsession he pretty much
brushed this to the side we see
throughout the movie that there's a
terry that's obsessed with numbers in
the count
and because of this in comparison to the
other beings he's a very short character
the other jerry's are taller symbolizing
that they've been able to grow
because they've found the beauty in a
lot of things in being 22's mentor
joe sort of passes on his world view to
her and she actually ends up having a
worse experience with him
than she did with the other mentors who
let her down joe actually manages to
make it back into his body
after casting 22 to the side and he gets
his big gig
everything goes off without a hitch it's
the moment that he'd hoped for his
entire life
but something something just feels empty
now this should feel like a win but
because he's pretty much focused on this
at the expense of others
there's no one to celebrate it with so
he spends his night alone in his
apartment
looking over some of the things that 22
collected on earth
these symbols pretty much represent how
much fun she had living his life
and in many ways she enjoyed it more
than he did
thus the hollow victory of finally
getting to play jazz has meant that he's
missed out on some of the joys in life
and has also let 22 down joe can easily
travel to the zone whenever he wishes to
through music
but if he spends all his time there
he'll be like the other miserable
zombies that roam the realm completely
empty with no purpose in life outside of
this one thing
joe inspired by the tokens that she
collected and his own experiences goes
back into the zone
and we see that because he instilled in
her this belief that life should be only
about one thing
that she has a very negative view i kind
of view this almost like a bushy parent
that forces their child into doing what
they wish they'd had
whether it's sport or art the choice is
being removed from the child as to
whether this is what they actually want
to do
and they end up existing solely for one
reason similar to what we see with joe
she clearly resents him and in her mind
he's a towering figure
that is pretty much the leader of the
mentors in the past who failed and let
her
down this apparition tells her that she
has no reason to live
i think this makes joe realize how much
he failed her
however joe breaks through to her and
tells her that she will find a reason
but that gets decided only when you live
in saving her life he also saves his own
and he decides to give 20 to the pass
which will allow her to travel to earth
joe jumps towards it with her and though
he can't go all the way
he can go as far as he can the jerry's
realize that he's come a long way
and they give him another chance on
earth the jerry asks what he's gonna do
and how he will spend his time
and joe just says that he doesn't know
we don't know what's gonna be around the
corner
but life is full of ups and downs that
make it worth living
but as long as we can appreciate what we
have and find people to share the
experience with
we will be living a fulfilling one now
this ending is deliberately left
ambiguous
however there were several plans by the
creators to give us concrete answers
in an interview with den of geek the
film's director peter doctor said
we storyboarded a bunch of stuff where
joe and 22 met
one of them was in new york 22 was like
a student that joe later recognizes
in another one she actually ended up in
india as a kid living there
however in the end they decided to leave
these answers up to the audience
and doctors stated it's kind of one of
those things where i feel like if the
audience falls in love with these
characters
i would rather that they have their own
answers to where they ended up
rather than trying to provide all those
answers for them
for me it's a really great joy when you
can create these things that have a life
of their own
that sparks a whole story for someone
else this is why i really liked the
ending of the movie
and throughout joe's life he'd had this
drive to do one thing
but found something else entirely in the
movie before playing on stage he does
state that his life is just about to
begin
by the end we discover that there's
actually an alternate thing behind it
his life begins in the end because he
finds something else beyond his
obsession
and he realizes that jazz shouldn't be
the only reason he's alive
22 and joe both learn how to live from
one another and now they will experience
all the ups and downs
finding joy in them doctors stated that
the last line of the film is going to be
i'm going to enjoy every moment of it
however
in the end they decided to change it to
just live because
it's impossible to enjoy each and every
moment of life
it's a better understanding of what it
means to be alive and i absolutely
love this change as it carries a lot
more with it
the film ends with terry telling
everyone to go home
and though this is sort of a
post-credits scene it actually carries
the meaning that we should go out
and make the most of what we have in the
end seoul was a blast
and for me it gets an 8.5 out of 10.
now don't forget that on the 30th of
december we're giving away three copies
of the lord of the rings 4k box set to
our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the film the links to our
socials are in the description
and you can also support the channel by
clicking the join button below
and as a thank you you get videos like
this early if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
breakdown of wonder woman 1984 which
will be linked on screen
right now we go over the entire thing
and give our thoughts on its ending
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want to know more without the way
thank you for sticking through the video
i've been paul you've been the best and
i'll see you next time
take care peace